il n'est pas possible que les éleveurs
soient comme cela à la merci d'une
variation tels des cours à la production
cela signifie pour une perte si forte
qu'ils ne peuvent plus investir qui
peuvent plus typés qui peuvent plus
acheter le matériel qui désirent coûte
plus cher le moment où leurs bêtes moins
cher il faut absolument avoir une
politique intelligente et cohérente à la
fois de nos fils de la viande et des
importations c'est quand même anormal
qu'on voit des importations qui viennent
dans ce trio tandis que l'office de la
viande semble ne pas savoir exactement
ce qu'il doit faire bon alors j'ajoute
que un deuxième point paraît capital csu
de la formation des jeunes vous le
disiez vous même tout à l'heure les
techniques de l'élevage doivent à partir
de l'expérience des anciens qui est une
expérience très utile doivent aller vers
des
formes modernes qui permettent peut-être
d'aller plus vite
et en même temps enfin de là donc
d'avoir un meilleur rendement mais cette
formation de jeunes qui est absolument
nécessaire qui est réclamé en premier
lieu parle vous savez par le centre
national des jeunes agriculteurs a est
également trop négligé moi je pense
absolument gérer presque le premier
point d'une politique agricole c'est de
miser à fond sur la formation de la
jeunesse est donc de donner les crédits
correspondants
parce qu'on ne peut pas tout faire à la
fois il a précisé ce qu'il ferait dès
son arrivée au pouvoir
en six mois en 18 mois en cinq ans le
succès de mai et l'équilibré financier
de chaque étape
permettant d'aborder l'étape suivante
les mesures de la première étape seront
naturellement
mise en route immédiatement par le
nouveau gouvernement et qui est là je
reprends des expressions de mitre en lui
même ne promettra jamais que le possible
sans aller jamais au delà de ces
ressources ne paiera pas en fausse
monnaie
fera ses choix avec courage pour
soutenir la production pour maîtriser
l'inflation la hausse des prix et le
chômage
ce plan nécessite évidemment le concours
de tout le pays et toutes ses classes et
tous ces groupes
pour réussir
il doit être mise en oeuvre par des
hommes qui ont la confiance de tous ceux
qui travaillent et de tous ceux qui
produisent